good afternoon everybody welcome to the
sad to say final panel of comic New York
thank you my name is Jeremy dabber for
those of you who don't know and I am one
of the co-organizers along with Danny
finger off and Karen green of this event
and I wanted to start my introduction my
brief introduction with a brief
autobiographical moment which is that my
first encounter with scholarship really
came in the pages of Marvel comic books
not about marvel comics books that is
not not academic scholarship about them
but the comic books themselves because
they were as men for many of you this
may be the case might in your first
encounter with a footnote right and we
didn't wear numbers right but there were
these little asterisks and they referred
back to some previous textual material
on the issue and I was very lucky that
in the person of my uncle Zack I had a
repository a library of earlier comics
that I could assiduously go back and
discover the earlier material to which
was referenced it was also the time in
the letters pages where I found and you
should forgive me as the director of the
Institute for his real Jewish Studies
the Talmudic level of complicated
observation and attempted reconciliation
that would go on among what we would
call fans or scholars who themselves
were trying to write their own
commentaries on all of the textual
material that was in front of them so
that was my first as I say encounter
with with sort of comics and an academy
of readers and lovers and followers as
well then as beginning to meet being
lucky enough in this position to meet
many of the creators as we and hear from
them as we have over the last two days
to see as I became a cat became involved
with this the tremendous amount of
scholarship that goes into creating and
producing and thinking about the works
themselves whether it's the research
material that's gathered in order to
write or the visual research material
the libraries in order to in order to
draw on provide reference material in
that respect and so it seemed that
coming into the University
an age when comic studies was beginning
to really take hold for the first time
in the Academy it seemed like a natural
outgrowth of my own and so many other
people's interests and so as a result
i'm truly delighted not only to be
involved with this as an organizer but
to be chairing this panel as well and i
am particularly delighted to have a
distinguished intelligent and
good-looking panel to to my left and i
would like to check in on the talmud did
you to tell you a little bit and witty
tell you a little bit about them each
and i am going to start with the figure
on my furthest left and that is chris
couch who we owe a great debt to not
only for serving on this panel but as
karen said yesterday in her introduction
providing the inspiration for having an
event at columbia to begin with and this
is in so yes please chris himself is a
son of columbia in his fair to say he
holds a undergraduate masters and
doctoral degrees in art history from
this August institution and is a
prolific publisher of material of
articles not only on Latin American art
but on comics as well and they include
among other things that work on another
distinguished graduate of Columbia Jerry
Robinson or an alumnus of Columbia and
they will eisner companion and he has
taught are comics as art and literature
at the School of Visual Arts University
of Massachusetts Amherst and he is
currently a visiting associate professor
in American Studies at Trinity
University coming to his right is
Jonathan Gray at John Jay College and a
CUNY who works on a dazzling variety of
subjects including post World War two
American literature and culture
african-american literature comic books
black masculinity race in popular
culture his first book innocence by
association civil rights and the white
literary imagination will be published
in the fall and he's currently working
on another project to follow project on
race and comic books
he is a new friend I think it's fair to
say but and I'm following him on Twitter
as you all well should be tweeting
regularly so yeah I don't know if it's
TMI but you know maybe and now to my
nearest left Paul Levitz and i would say
that Paul Evans is probably best known
as the winner of two best fantasy and
comic fan art awards maybe maybe not
he's probably best known as a the writer
on some of the Legion of super-heroes
most successful runs in its long and
distinguished history the trade
collected Edition the great darkness
saga as was a New York Times bestseller
and his recent monumental book and I
mean this in every sense it weighs about
15 or 20 pounds from taschen if 75 years
of DC Comics the art of modern
myth-making recently won an eisner award
my personal favorite part about Paul
Levitz is resume is that he is now
teaching at Columbia University seminar
on American Studies and he and I will be
teaching what I believe is the first
course on the american graphic novel
next year at columbia so please welcome
all of our panel
and I wanted to begin by just thinking
about this panel in the way that we
think about the multiplicity of tasks
that take place among people in the
Academy and that is that we are among
other than we are teachers we teach
undergraduates we teach and train
graduate students we do research of our
own right and and and teaches graduate
students how to do research and then in
some sense along with another part of
the university other part which is the
libraries we help to serve as custodians
of this material as well we preserve it
we collect it we put it in order an
organized order that makes sense and so
I wanted to take the panel and get their
observations and insights about each of
these different areas serially and so
the first question that I'm going to
throw out is about as I say teaching and
since this is a panel not on comics in
general but about comic New York and
specific i want to ask when you guys are
thinking about how your teaching courses
how you're arranging your courses and
you're introducing maybe two people
comics in general where does new york
figure in your courses how do you use
this to think about comics as a whole
and in about New York and its place in
comics and i'll start with chris if you
don't mind Chris please start us off one
of the things that I think about in
terms of comics and the Academy is where
do comics fit in terms of disciplines oh
oh it to load no oh a lot closer okay
one of the things I think about with
comics and where it fits is what
discipline to comic spin it should be
English should it be our history in my
own career the first time I was hired to
teach comics was at the University of
Massachusetts at Amherst and I was hired
into the department of comparative
literature and the chair who hired me at
that time bill maybe has said that he
had incorporated children's literature
into the comparative literature program
because his twelve-year-old daughter had
said to him dad why don't you teach the
books I care about okay so I met him at
a panel at words and pictures Museum in
Northampton and he said I've been
looking for someone like you because I
was an editor at kitchen sink press but
I had my PhD in art history from
Columbia he said
i've incorporated children's literature
this was 1996 I want comics in
comparative literature and so I started
teaching one class a semester in comics
at UMass and I've been doing that since
then teaching comics at the University
of Massachusetts Amherst in comparative
literature when I got the chance to
teach at Trinity I was hired by Paul
Lauder who's a monument in American
Studies he began his career as a
undergraduate in college as a member of
a thing called the SDS which you might
have heard of students for the
Democratic Society and he's been
involved with alternative education and
radical education initiatives for his
entire life and he hired me to teach
comics at Trinity unit Trinity College
in Hartford and I'm very pleased to do
that and then I also want to thank
rebecca gay for connecting me with
marshall ehresmann to teach history of
comics in the graduate program in
illustration at the School of Visual
Arts and when Marshall ehresmann hired
me he said to me look when I went to
school we knew what the hierarchies were
you know that you know architecture was
at the top painting and sculpture was
there illustration was here and comics
they were they didn't even count and he
said our students now do not internalize
those hierarchies they believe these are
all arts and they need to know about the
history of comics so I find that comics
or something that really crosses
disciplinary boundaries but that the
disciplines that are the most open to
comics are the ones that are really open
to world literatures and to radical
perspectives and I think that goes back
to talk about comics as a democratic
medium yesterday that came up a little
bit when i teach comics my basic comic
is a comics course is a history of
comics from the yellow kid to mouse and
that's a very New York Center course ok
I teach the yellow kid as the first
comic strip because it was the first
strip to appear at a newspaper and it
was invented in the New York of
vaudeville and get each theater and
things like that and and just was a huge
cultural phenomenon I was actually
reading Edmund Wilson's the 20s a year
or so ago and in there there's an
anecdote from the 1920s about a
socialite sleeping with a boxer and to
make fun of him Edmund Wilson says oh he
reads the comics the yellow kid and all
that and this is in the 1920s and the
comics were still the yellow kid and
then of course we do you know
superheroes ec comics it's all about New
York you know comics were first invented
in New York by the Eastern color
printing salesman and the 30s comic
books didn't exist before that and then
of course will eisner is you know the
father of the graphic novel so it's a
very New York centered course and I
think the students really appreciate
that the you know ethnic diversity the
the creativity sometimes the marginality
of the Jewish creators I also teach a
class in Judaic Studies on the history
of the Jewish graphic novel at the
University of Massachusetts which is
funded by a the pose and foundation for
jewish secularism and i'm very pleased
to do that Thank You Jonathan yeah so
for me I i begin sort of with myself the
reason one of the things one of the
tools that i use to become literate and
arm was comic books right and so when i
began you know an english degree and and
and then eventually a PhD in english i
kept that the things i would learn you
know about you know rhizomes and
deconstruction and and and all of these
things i'm like a wait this is happening
here right and so a lot of these you
know just sort of but working through
analog i was able to sort of better
understand literary theory and you know
sort of the scope of literature through
my earlier childhood experience with
comics and so what i find i'm at cuny
when I teach comics is um people are one
incredibly enthused to finally be able
to you know work with something that
actually this we can do this here right
and it's incredibly exciting for them
arm and and then it's an easy way into
literary theory and into some of the
things that are important to me right um
and so of course I am you know sorry to
Paul but I will sort of raised on marvel
comics but and and and we talked about
this and in fact in my you know I'm
working on a book on race and comics and
I was just I'm just have a draft of the
Luke Cage chapter and thinking about
luke cage's debut in 1972 in light of
Attica and in light of the death of
George Jackson right and so and so
because marvel comics were placed in the
real world
it's it's so much easier to sort of make
these connections than it is if you're
talking about opal City or stars where
is Star City exactly right um and so you
know so for me teaching this this course
I don't go that far back i actually
start in the 1960s and move forward
that's but you know i'm a post-world war
two scholar but i am able to tie in so
much of American culture and it's all
it's all there thank you Chris and thank
you Paul it's all there it's all
embedded in in the text itself if you
know how to look and where to look so
that's how it goes ok it's a New York
story you know my grandfather worked in
New stand on the lower east side in the
Depression years I like to imagine that
he might have sold some of those first
prototype comic books or he might have
been the one that max gains walked past
with the ones with a 10-cent sticker on
them and stuff them in he did that
because there was no work for Taylor's
or whatever the male equivalent of
seamstress was in the sweatshops in the
Depression years so he had lost his
natural employments who was working 16
hours in that the newspaper comics were
born here in the circulation wars the
comic books were born here Eastern color
DC off the press of the Brooklyn Eagle
at the bottom of Fulton Street the
generation that led the business of
comics came into comics here as
immigrants off the boat because
LaGuardia ran an anti porn campaign that
drove them out of the stuff they were
selling up to the next highest rung on
the on the ladder and one inch above
porn and pulps was comic books that's a
really little steps on that ladder and
the vast majority of the early great
comic book creators were kids on the
streets of New York whether they went
straight into comics or where they went
through the fleischer animation studios
which were
here peculiarly in those days and one of
the great breeding grounds of talent for
them so it all started here and it
really isn't until you get to about 1981
or 1982 that you begin to have the story
splinter out across the rest of the
country you had little bits with the
underground comics and the excitement
that that was causing but there were no
regularly producing comic book
publishers to go to work for outside New
York until first in Pacific about
nineteen eighty or so so it's we had a
lot of time to incubate this field to
make that happen and if you're telling
the history of comics you're telling a
New York story will leave aside all the
material that goes inside the pages and
inside the fiction whether it was
cunningly disguised as Gotham and
metropolis I don't think that was that
hard to figure out or no
they get confused out there but that
it's a New York story at the end of the
day one of the things that's come out
already in the answers that you're
seeing is the tremendous number of if
you're thinking like an academic
bureaucrat as i sometimes am the
greatest number of disciplines and
departments and centers and
possibilities that that comics could act
in it could be an art history or english
or his or history what are some of this
is a two-part question or two different
kinds of questions what are the kinds of
disciplines that you guys feel most
comfortable doing research in and how
does your comics research change by the
fact that you have to in some sense
listen to the tools of a particular
discipline and also and i'd be
interested they're going to be as many
answers probably as there are people who
think about this but what is the
greatest area of scholarly lack that
research has to be done in in comics
that is if you had one area a graduate
student came to you and said i could
work on anything in the world in comics
what's the area that's needed the most
and you can answer either or both of
these questions and and i'm looking at
jonathan so i'm going to look at i'm
going to ask you first that's fine um
well sitting in the audience is one of
my graduate students who is doing a
dissertation on women's comics so i will
plug both my project in hers i think
that while we have a great understanding
of the way that particularly Jewish
identity you know plays out inside the
medium of comics both from it from from
from a business standpoint and from the
standpoint of some of the characters
looking at issues of race and gender
there's there's there's sort of a lot
less work done there right and so I
think that you know I mean I'm working
on a book on racing and comics she's
working on a dissertation that's going
to incorporate you know sort of women's
comics and and and and how that grows
and evolves and I think that um if you
that those will be two areas where one
could do
work and if justice justice step back
it's funny I also i'm advising i'm on a
dissertation committee in art history
even though i have a PhD in American
Studies in part because the person doing
the dissertation is writing his
dissertation on alternative comics and
no one in the art history department at
the CUNY grad center and knows anything
about comments at all right and so
they're looking at who inside CUNY know
something i do right um you know so
Chris getting back to what you're saying
yesterday by just raising your hand when
people want things done sure I can I can
be on that committee and so of course
I'm not comfortable inside art history I
wasn't trained as an art historian and
so and so but I think the place where
these things all overlap is in cultural
studies right cultural studies is is
what allows you to sort of you know
gesture towards history gesture towards
literature gesture towards art history
gesture towards sociology and political
science and also towards the law as well
right because I mean what does it mean
that you know if you guys are following
sort sort of contemporary comics right
you know where the discussion is about
the Patriot Act right i mean if you look
like The Avengers you know the so-called
civil war the Avengers this is all you
know just an allegory of the Patriot Act
right i mean if so there's a way in
which locating comic studies inside call
in interdisciplinary cultural studies
allows you to branch out into all these
different areas great and i'm going to
turn from someone who's come up in an
interdisciplinary approach american
studies in cultural studies to someone
who came out of a disciplinary approach
that is chris who came out through our
art history but it has now branched out
into a wide variety of area so of course
what's your take on this question well i
want to talk about what what research
needs to be done in comics first and
actually i would kind of answer that as
like everything more of everything yes
well um when I think of comic studies
today I compared it not to like you know
Knepper a film or anything like that but
19th century classical studies okay
where you know in the 1,800 1,700 but
really in the 1800s modern scholarship
and lighten meant based scholarship was
turning its attention to the texts from
the classical world and establishing
them for the first time
I think that's something that we haven't
done in comics at all which is
established our texts I mean what we
have is like the comic book price guide
you know okay and and the fans have done
very important things but I think that
we're in the position of 19th century
classical philology and we have to
establish what our texts are and and we
need to read them okay i went to a book
history conference two years ago and
michael suarez who's the head of the
rare book school at uva university of
virginia said one of his teacher said in
order to understand early printed books
you have to handle 5,000 of them and i
would say that scholars coming up these
days in order to understand comic books
and graphic novels you have to read at
least 5,000 of them okay not just sit
down every two graphic novels and think
you can write a dissertation on it you
have to read in the depths of the field
we don't know what was in all the Atlas
comics that Stanley edited in Jerry
Robinson drew so many stories for you
know people in graduate school now today
have not read all the work by will
Leisner that was published we have to
establish our texts and I think we are
really in the 19th century in terms of
scholarship and comics and we have a
long way to go and I want to say the
person who has really been the pioneer
in this and who was really establishing
the data in the field is John lent who
is the editor of the International
Journal of comic art which many when
people here have published in and that
is truly an international journal John
encourages young scholars from all
around the world especially Asia but
including Eastern Europe to document the
works in their cultural traditions and
to publish them in international journal
of comic art and he is really a font of
knowledge he's got the most extensive
personal archives on comics that I've
ever seen anywhere and I think that's
really important another program that I
think is really important and needs to
be acknowledged as Ohio State but even
before ohio state is mr. bill black
beard whose name we should all genuflect
before the man who saved the comics
because you know what build lacquer the
man who saved the comics the San
Francisco Academy of comic art now
housed at Ohio State University because
a microfilm of a comic strip is not a
comic strip a piece of original art of a
comic strip is not a comic strip a
printed color sunday comic strip is a
comic strip and we would not
have most of those without mr. bill
black beard and the archive that the
library and Lucy Caswell bought at house
at Ohio State and her successor Jenny
Rob are two of the major people who are
putting scholarship on a professional
basis and I think that Colombia is now
playing a role in that and I am so proud
that my alma mater is taking a stand and
helping create an archive for comics so
I'm gonna clap for that and we will get
back to questions of preservation and
archives which you've touched on as a
central part of this a little bit later
in our conversation but but following on
the first part of what you were saying
because I want to turn to Paul you know
if someone who really has spent decades
in the field of this has real intimate
familiarity with a lot of his and I was
coming to the field of scholarship I
think he one can say that the 75 years
of DC book was a work of real research
and scholarship what's your take now
coming into this side of the field from
this other side really having done some
of the work the chris was referring to
well i mean i have the first down
advertise that i'm a faux academic I
mean let's let's be serious here there's
six degrees on that side of the table
and there's none over here the the DC
book represents something I have deep
knowledge of but it's not the same as
diving in as an outside scholar and
researching something impartial e to
figure it out which is a whole other art
form I hope to exhibit some of those
behaviors in the remainder of my writing
days and live up to that standard but I
haven't haven't made that one yet I
support everything that was said I'd
identify a couple of things that I think
should be very high ordered that one
that was sort of touched on sideways and
but it should be hit dead center and
another that was not touched on which is
I think one of the things that makes
this radically different than the 19th
century literature for a moment the
thing that was touched on that I'd go a
little more strongly on is that the
existing body of comics scholarship
the scholars got into it was driven
almost entirely by the kinds of comics i
love the superhero comics you can find
online fairly easily three peoples guess
about who inked an issue of x-men that
wasn't credited and an articulate debate
about how that happened you can't find
who wrote all the romance comics you
can't find a word about major artists in
that field j scott pike party saph guys
who did that for years and years with
enormous audiences that's true as well
for some of the young children's comics
that were done and I think there's an
enormous body of research to be done
they're both in who the creators were
and what the fos of that material was
and how people responded to them to try
and bring that up to the snuff of the
the more mainstream commercial material
the other the thing that differentiates
it enormous I think from the 19th
century world is you still have primary
sources left check your stopwatch right
Irwin was doing fine this morning yes he
was we lost Shelley mold off this week
last week but got the last guy who had
work in action one who was alive we're
losing them pretty quick and frankly
we're losing their memories and their
minds faster than we're losing them
personally right I was talking to it may
be the same gal you were mentioning who
was doing the thesis on women comics
about going to talk to Marie Severin who
is still alive and on Long Island and I
think still with us mentally I i'm not
sure if anyone's heard more recently who
worked in EC's offices as the the only
woman of artistic bent there who was on
staff at marvel as the only woman artist
they're all those years right she'd have
some unique perspectives on something
like this you got a minute me and I'm
not shooting the particular gal who I
was talking to before I
but just to the field of scholarship in
general we're about to lose an enormous
body of knowledge in the next decade
where the last surviving people who were
part of all this process or who spoke
extensively to the people who did and we
really have we really have to get that
knowledge down Stan right um right you
know there the memories are the memories
are going already right but we're going
to lose the lab we're going to lose the
last shot any minute now and that's a
very very rich primary body of
information yeah oh please you know it's
actually just just to sort of double
down on what Paul is saying we were you
know we were chatting about the you know
the good old days of the 1980s and he
had said something that I didn't know
and then I was like I'd like wrote it
down like oh my god this is so important
that oh yeah that's when royalty payment
started and so that if you built and he
wouldn't he didn't describe it this way
but if you built a brand and people
bought more of your book that meant more
money coming to you and I'm just like oh
wow duh right and that but but that also
that also sort of is changing how I'm
beginning to think about this you know
there's projects I'll just like a
five-minute conversation so we need to
talk more but you know I mean and so and
so yes it's certainly true that we
should go and talk to as many as
possible one of the problems you have in
dealing with this field academically is
that as opposed I'd argue to to book
publishing which the business history of
and sort of the broad history of was
understood and and written down and
relatively stable by the time you get to
19th century literature Publishing's
been pretty similar for 100 or 150 years
before that I'm enough in academic to
draw the line more neatly um this
business has gone through four product
life cycles in in 75 years with utterly
different business models
different sort of rules of the game that
have dramatic effect on how all this
happened and you need to understand how
those things kind of synchronize and
drive it the kind of run that Chris had
on x-men which generated the insightful
notes that now have found a home at
Columbia was extraordinarily unlikely to
have happened to generation before or
generation since in part because of
changes in the business condition right
if the royalty structures had not come
in place despite the fact that he was
the most commercial writer of our
generation in comics there would have
been a hell of a lot better
opportunities for him to do other things
he would have ended up as a novelist
full-time or going off into some other
medium all these things connect as part
of the story and you really do need a
very multidisciplinary approach but it's
also the business schools on some level
and the business or business history I
want to build on pawn wait on what
you're saying and ask the entire panel
about the interactions between academics
and scholars within the Academy and
other institutions that are either
outside the Academy or para academic and
that what what i mean by that by that
fancy word is a things both like comic
con's which are a source of these things
and places like the mla or other kinds
of scholarly institutions that are not
within the purview of the Academy
directly right so I'm going to start
with you Paul maybe talk about you have
a story about comic-con and then and
then go that way defense of it
it may be I mean story's being written
as we go we'll see where it develops
from there but a fair point Chris I'll
try to do this anecdote as quickly as i
can so 15-20 years ago I get a phone
call from professor named Randy Duncan
down at Hendrickson state lovely man who
I knew from some years ago when he read
an article that I had written for the
comics journal called a call for higher
criticism asking for some of these
academics to come in and pick apart but
crap we were doing and tell us what we
were doing where if it fit in the
history i'm randy said i want a radical
one of these things colloquia symposium
or something on comics and popular
culture down here at Hendrickson DC
gonna give me some money that's exactly
my answer I kind of laughed pretty
quickly and then I said no seriously
Brandi Arkansas um that's I'm sure it's
a lovely state I've managed not to set
foot there I think you can have a hard
time getting people down there never
mind that we're not sending you any
money why don't you call the guys who
run the San Diego comic-con because they
are not-for-profit and they need to do
things educationally every now and then
to justify their existence and see if
they'll give you some rooms in the back
room of the convention because really
they they've got space they're not using
and this will help them justify their
stuff to keep their tax status and I
think every professor would much rather
be in san diego in August and Arkansas
in February just a wild guess
um and I think that was one of my more
useful contributions as a publisher over
the years it's been running I don't know
how many 15 years something like that
and admin probably would have happened
of its own course in some fashion or
another if had I not been the part of it
but I'm very proud of it regardless and
yep there's like there's kind of a
couple of different names attached to
different pieces of it and that starts
getting into the politics of the
different guys but right right so I'm
going to switch the gentleman talk about
the MLA where politics has never ever
appeared at no never so there's it so um
the MLA is split into various groups or
factions or where how we want to
describe them and so in the MLA is the
is the Modern Language Association which
is the is the the sort of umbrella group
for all teachers of literature whether
literature in english and german and
spanish what have you and so every year
there's this huge conference and it
rotates from city to city and you have
annual meetings of you know
Shakespearean scholars is a
Shakespearean group and Victorian
scholars and African American scholars
and what have you and so there is now as
of three years ago a discussion group in
graphic narratives right and part of
what this means is that there is now
reserved space at every MLA four panels
on you know from different professors on
on some element of comics right and I
happen to serve on the board of the MLA
discussion group and we were able to
invite danny to come out to seattle to
be the moderator to be the model to be
the respondent on our panel called the
material history of spider-man and so
just looking at you know spider-man it
was it was the anniversary and so we
were looking at the evolution of
spider-man and of course this made it
into the New York Times via a
disparaging comment by Stanley fish
about you know looking through this
year's MLA I see that there's a panel on
the material history of spider-man and
this is the kind of thing that used to
get us into trouble um and so you know
and so into you know there still is
resistance from an older guard and from
a different faction but it
it's actually been quite fruitful
serving on the board and and and and one
of the things you do you have to do when
you're when you're a part of an area's
you have to collaborate with another
area every year a different area and so
it's quite interesting everyone's like
Oh okama comments comics and they're
sort of reaching out and we actually in
like we were initially worried about you
know sort of reaching out to like
Shakespeare ians how about doing
something about Sandman and comics and
them laughing at us but instead we've
actually never had to reach out it's
always been some of the more established
reaching to us saying oh my god our
students want what you're doing can we
have a panel you know to tie in so that
we can sort of unlike sure why not right
and so and so this this is definitely a
sign of sort of how how things are going
in the future that you know all the
panels are well attended and and people
want more and so I mean every year the
context presence at MLA grows and grows
and so I think it's it's a sign of
Health for for this intellectual project
Chris are there other institutions that
you're thinking of that well I'd like to
first of all say something about what
Paul said about retrieving our memories
and I want to do a little shout-out to
Charles Kotchman and Abrams and their
comics arts line because they've been a
Charles has done an amazing job bringing
out books about our great oh I'm sorry
about about our great writers I got to I
had the honor of doing a book on Jerry
Robinson which was based on two years of
interviews and but it's really tough to
do a book like that it is very hard to
find a publisher that would be
interested in doing a book on you know
any of our great artists or writers they
just will not publish it on even an
academic press it's it's difficult and
if you want to do a book like that in
your a scholar you have to somehow get a
grant from you know the national
endowment for the humanities or someone
like that and it's very tough to get
those kind of grants because one of the
problems that academia has and again
this is what Marshall ehresmann said to
me the students don't have the
hierarchies in their heads anymore but
the institutions have hierarchies the
academics have hierarchies and
you know even in the MLA there's a
comics discussion group but as far as
allowing material based on comics in two
panels on general topics like you know
autobiography or you know 20th century
literature those topics are not allowed
in other panels I think comics are still
geto wised in academia it's hard to
publish things on comics unless you're
doing it with a special depress and
again McFarland and University Press of
Mississippi both deserve our deep thanks
for the publishing programs that they
have but it's just very hard to publish
material like that because academia is
still all about hierarchies and I think
I think that it's comic scholars that's
something that we have to resist as we
build our scholarship on comics is to
incorporate those kind of hierarchies in
our own works i was reading an anthology
of articles on autobiographical comics
recently and one of the articles began
with the sentence since art spiegelman
raised the level of the genre of funny
animal comics with mouse and i was just
horrified and i said no you know we
accept this material for what it is we
are finding the value in this popular
culture that was read by millions of
people and created by adults for adults
often that's one of the great things
Jerry told me we wrote the comics for
ourselves we drew them for ourselves you
know we have to try to resist the
hierarchies that academia may impose on
us as we do our own scholarship you know
in in comics and we have to be the
people that you know change that field
um if I can just a light enlighten that
that message a little bit via the this
forthcoming the forthcoming MLA is going
to be in Boston and the discussion group
of which I'm a part is actually
partnering with the MLA division on
autobiography biography and life writing
and so there is going to be the formal
collaboration on a panel called graphic
lives in wartime so I mean again I think
that what you're saying is true but I
think it's also less and less true i
mean this is they have a lot of clout
and again they came to us and said you
know the growth industry and an
autobiography is in graphic you know
these these life stories people are
telling with pictures can you can we
partner so that we can have a formal
discussion about this and we're like
sure because they have more money than
we do
I think I think what's clear is that
we're in this period of transition and
I'd like to segue into the final
question because I want to allow some
time for people to ask questions of
their own and to ask you guys about your
for your advice on a transition that's
taking place here as well with in
Colombia narrowly and that's at the
library's this conference I think is
dedicated to a real celebration of a
moment of transition really headed over
by our Karen green in which with the
assistance and support of the rare books
and manuscripts library in the library
as a whole we've really become
interested in collecting and as i said
earlier in my introduction this is one
of our functions in the Academy's as a
custodian of preserver in a cannon Iser
and so I asked you on Karen's behalf
even though she didn't put me up to this
for advice which is how do we columbia
university in the city of New York right
with the gong comic New York how our
best way of going about archiving and
collecting materials what should we be
thinking about in this in this function
of our academic job what are some of the
factors we should be think about any
advice for for us and by us of course I
mean Karen and I'm going to start with
Jonathan and then go around our way sure
um well I actually want to want to just
make a point before I actually answer
that question it's you know prior to
Karen doing the heroic work that she's
been doing it's sort of ridiculous that
um you know comics are born in New York
and if you want to go to the archives
the arc the best archives are at
Michigan State and Ohio State right this
would this would be the equivalent of
there being no film school in Los
Angeles like oh like how does that even
be right and so I think that there is a
space for you know a sort of
interdisciplinary center of comic
studies that should live in New York
City because New York City is where the
there is right and so I think that you
know to ask the question of how to
properly archived is um which I will get
around to answering is but is to is to
actually aim too low right
as particularly because let's let's just
use Columbia as a hypothetical given
that there are so many armed comics
turned into films right and so given
that like the film school would would
want a piece of this right given that
there's a tremendous interest in art
history in English in history in jewish
studies because of the you know the the
pioneers in the field it should be
fairly easy to one would think given in
the absence of hierarchies and
bureaucracy to actually you not stop
laughing but you would think in the
absence of all these other competing
interests that it would sort of be a
natural fit you know and g look the
institution's expanding their building a
whole new campus what might go there I'm
so you know you would you would think
that um you know given this the
centrality of comics to our culture at
the current moment and given this long
New York history of it that you know
there should be a New York institution
that would do even more that would give
that would invest in care and even more
power but to answer to answer your
question I mean I think that um I think
it's a yes and model we have to take
everything on we have to take the arm
you know the microfiche and the the
original art and the arm and the actual
newspaper print that was printed on um I
mean there's so much out there you know
that I mean that the archive couldn't
can just grow and grow and grow I mean
at this point because it's so young and
so burgeoning that there should be
almost no discrimination at all let's
just take it all and figure out how to
make sense of it you know that's a bad
student support right I did not say
those were to any gratitude psychology
well I'm proud that a writer like Chris
Claremont's papers are coming here but I
know one of the things that the Special
Collections at Columbia has done for a
long time is collectin and care about
illustration I know they have not only
arthur rackham art but his paint box
which came from his daughter so I I
would like to see artists donate their
art to Columbia I think that would help
get the attention of
the art history department here which
actually has its own gallery and it
would it would in a sense fit with their
collections because they the collections
here I believe care about the history of
book illustration the history of books
the history of illustration and although
i don't think that artists who draw
comics are in fact illustrators i think
their collaborators with the writers in
a way that illustrators are not right
but i think that that kind of artistic
mission as well as the literary mission
would be a way for the columbia library
special collections to make a lot of
sense out of comics in a way that they
could understand and that would match up
with their missions and i'd like to see
that happen great paul last word ah stop
us from throwing stuff out you know in
all seriously the extraordinary thing
about Chris's donation in part is both
the meticulousness with which he worked
and the fact that he has it hmm well
from from my hackish perspective but
what's the fact that survived you know
to the extent that i ever do stuff in
the fashion that Chris doesn't planning
a story it goes in the trash can five
minutes later and it has all my whole
career hey I'm it still does this week
well about doing that that becomes the
question if if in fact there is going to
be a real home for these things then the
comic book professionals and even the
comic book publishing companies need to
be educated as a first step that there
is a is a home that will take these
children hang on a couple of real
practical steps that Warner Brothers
understands that UCLA has a film archive
that Warner Brothers gets to have some
influence over and that will take
essentially the outbox from Warner
Brothers every day and that stuff will
go there so an awful lot of stuff is
preserved strictly because it's going to
go somewhere where the studio isn't
going to have to pay to keep it
and they can go back and look DC as a
division of Warner Brothers puts its
stuff in the recycle bin because there
is no archive for it to go to and DC did
a much better job than Marvel did of
preserving any kind of library of its
material through the 50s perform before
my time I take no credit for this um I
didn't throw it out and I can't I kept
it up when it was my turn with some
library books with little library pocket
cards pasted in him when I was 16 years
old working as an assistant editor but
you have to as a first step establish
that this exists and that it is funded
enough when the Eisner archives went to
Ohio State they in part they went to
Ohio State with ohio state requiring a
donation to sort them and manage them
and take care of them to take custody of
them you have there's a whole art form
which I don't pretend to understand but
that presumably Columbia has some great
deep expertise on to figure out how to
fund the people to go through Chris's
stuff and organize it grad students or
whatever interns both you can still got
to feed them you still get the track of
them the more you can set up an official
welcome for this the more chance there
will be for stuff to be turned over and
the more you can reach out or at early
stages and say to the people who you're
interested in you know we we might like
your stuff someday and University of
Wyoming has been very good at that for
quite a number of years you know long
before I had any rational thought of
sending any anything anywhere I had a
letter from them saying you know before
you die can you just send us everything
not really thinking so but okay great
thank you I think we have time for some
questions or comments so for posterity
sake now that we've talked about
collecting please if you have a question
come up to the microphone and that way
it will be sure to be heard by
everybody including the cameras yes sort
of hi I just want to say one thing that
was overlooked and when you gave credits
for Paul I believe he didn't mention his
first credit should be he was a chief
executive at DC Comics for over 30 years
and it was under his tutelage that he
oversaw groundbreaking works like Dark
Knight and watchmen that really brought
DC Comics into the modern era and I just
think that has to be acknowledged for
Paul appreciate it but overstated Arlen
I was hurt is so amended thank you yeah
I I wasn't the head of the company in
the years that we first published those
books I find out you had certainly was
involved all those years but jenette
Kahn was the leading creative force in
the company in those years so what's not
I've that I've done enough I can stand
it I can stand on my own list thank you
and then my other comment and this has
to do with New York is that and this is
no offense or at all the criticism of
Will Eisner but it seems to be common
perception that he is the father of the
graphic novel the bottom line is is that
a contract with God is a collection of
short stories and Jim Steranko who is a
living legend created really the first
intentional graphic novel in 1976 called
Chandler and for reasons that I'd like
to hear maybe the three of you expound
on why Jim Steranko does not get the
credit for really creating the first
modern graphic novel two years before
Eisner I just like to hear your reaction
to because I don't think he did I'm an
enormous fan of Jim's work both as a
historian as a creator what makes
contract with God pivotal was wills
desire to have it published as
literature and brought to the world the
fact that he turned down other forms of
publishing the fact that he co-funded
some of the publishing with baronet to
get it out there that he insisted on
coming out as a hardcover going into
traditional bookstores many are those
are things that Jim would certainly have
to do or try to do as well he simply
didn't succeed in them right point that
as we heard in the earlier panel when
you're talking particularly the two
young women who have come up in a much
later era of the business than I have
who point to contract with God as their
starting point there have been long form
comics for a long time Chandler's an
extraordinary piece of work
extraordinary in its courage at the time
McGregor and Rogers detectives Inc at
pretty much the same moment as contract
with God and then there was saber by
glaceon that was 78 yep there's a number
of pieces that come together in this
trend but when you go back as I think as
a historian and again I'll defer to
those with the degrees the turning point
becomes wills work be right and it's
really in many ways his work as the
Evangelist of the graphic novel that is
much more relevant than his work as the
father of it he he did it by
demonstrating what could be done he did
it by putting his money where his is
where his mouth was again and again and
it's just it's an extra I also thing I
sinners were transcended the genre and
it was the subject matter in the series
of it whereas Steranko was Jean or a
fiction set in New York City a film noir
graphic novel and I think it was also
the seriousness the subject matter that
gave eyes near the edge or lightning
didn't strike there now and at the end
of the day you know some part of it is
you just have to look back and say what
did actually happen right thank you very
much Danny oh I'm sorry ma'am I had a
question but I think actually Jonathan
answered it with his proposal so my
question had to do with what about those
of us who are in fields that have not
been mentioned that are themselves
interdisciplinary and that are beginning
to make use of graphic novels
extensively and I teach in an area here
columbia called narrative medicine and
in medical humanities a lot of people
are beginning to use graphic novels and
we're wonderful narratives and really
there is medical schools they're using
our graduate programs but we don't have
the resources typically I mean we pick
Karen's brain all the time but an
interdisciplinary Center would actually
that let her off the hook a little bit
rise and bring a lot more people in and
we would be able to access more of the
literature which we don't know not being
scholars in the area right and we'd also
get some training and how to close Rida
graphic not right what are you know the
sort of fundamentals that you're all
talking about for the what are the
seminal novels that we should know about
and how do we look at them right so
you've answered the question but I just
guess I want to let people know that
there are others out there oh of course
who would really want to use this
there's a there's a there's a scholar at
Duke named Priscilla walled who does a
lot of work into this interdisciplinary
work on literary studies and on science
as well and like she and I have been in
conversation in part because I'm like
hey well you know what do you think of
like of my cancer diaries for example
she's like oh I haven't really looked at
that I'm Michael hairs and so I mean
again in the absence of a place to host
someone to have that discussion you know
in the absence you know then it's just
sort of like I can like share these
three emails we've exchanged right but
um but you're right i mean that's that's
the other thing as soon as you create a
center suddenly there are you know there
are requests like that one and then it's
like well how do we do that oh well fine
we just invite Priscilla wall from do
can we bring this other person from here
and then we have a discussion and now we
have a symposium and now you're getting
what you need right again this is why
it's sort of are there any
administrators here anyway this is why
it's sort of crazy that they're like in
me it's not just it's not just Columbia
I'm just happy to say this because I'm
here I mean NYU CUNY for them I mean
like how can there be no place in New
York it doesn't make any sense right and
so um yes even for for reasons that
aren't even occurring to me as I'm
saying it you know it this seems to be a
natural thing that should eventually
happen didn't Paul say comics were just
one rung above pornography well but I
mean there's pornography studies to come
on there
I think in in in the valley in
california Danny I'm just to go back to
your original question of what's missing
in the world of comics studies as
someone who teaches various aspects of
comics history you know how to
appreciation the vote the vocabulary and
this is a problem that film studies had
25 years ago right that still has is
when you talk to students or other other
academics about comics it's almost
always well what is the story what
happens next it's like reading a movie
review that forgets that it's a visual
medium so right what's missing and I
think it's connected to the history
historical and and preservation is that
aspect is an appreciation of comics as a
medium that is not you know it's that is
not a offshoot of film or an offshoot of
the novel but is sequential art or
comics or whatever so I know it's a long
struggle and film studies is still not
there but sort of is that being
addressed or do you see that is
happening or is it or for the time being
as comics always going to tag on to
other departments for now comics are
always tagging on to other departments I
you know one of the problems with the
Disciplinary you know structure of
academia is that I I don't know of
anyone except Hillary shoot at Chicago
who has been hired primarily to teach
comics right everyone else who has been
hired they do children's literature if
you like comments you to Southern
literature you know no one has been
hired primarily to teach comics I do all
popular culture at a couple of places
that I teach and it's just not
considered to be something that you
would hire a faculty member to do that's
one reason why we don't have the
research we do because there's no one to
advise PhDs right you know in these
things it's not considered to be really
a part of academia I would like to say
art history is a discipline that really
could contribute to comics that I love
my colleagues in literature
right about comics but oftentimes they
you know they haven't been trained in
visual analysis they don't know the
history of art and if you talk to any
artist if you talked to Chris where they
know the history of art backwards and
forwards they're constantly referring to
things you know visually that you know
American Impressionism is a major
feature of Jimmy Corrigan right and and
you know most people are just not going
to know that because they don't know the
history of art I know Persepolis all of
these books will eisner was steeped in
the ashcan school I mean things specific
compositions taken from paintings of the
ashcan school a period his graphic
novels you know as one Jewish theater
and everything in fact to study comics
you need to know everything right and
it's like it it's like studying film I
mean we think there's a timeline or a
way to get comics to the point where
film studies are now I mean it's it's
people study people look at the same
text over and over and over again and
they do it for precisely this reason
right because you know the text has this
to offer it has that to offer has this
other thing I mean this is why you know
an interdisciplinary an
interdisciplinary approach that you know
calls attention to the fact that there's
no one way to actually get at this right
is so important like one of the one of
the areas that were my biggest
frustration is the imposition of austere
theory on to comics right and so it's
like oh this is stan lee's this is not
Stan leaves this is Stan Lee and Steve
did codes right and then followed by
Stanley in and and and and and genre
mitas followed by Stanley and and
Stanley and or you know al amor al amor
with the other more didn't draw a thing
right I mean and I revere Alan Moore
right but you can't then you can't start
calling things Alan Moore's or chris
claremont without you know pointing to
the collaboration right and so I think
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done I mean so sure on the one hand this
is Art Spiegelman's right Art Spiegelman
has done every little thing but you
can't then apply that method of
criticism to talk about chris claremont
x-men because they are wonderful but
it's not just his right and so we have
to then begin to form a new sort of
vocabulary to discuss in it but
it exists in art right i mean people
don't necessarily understand that for
example Tarantino has had the same
cinematographer for all of his films and
his latest film django unchained which
I'm terrified of this is going to be the
first film he does without that
cinematographer right and so now and so
it's a film about slavery and it's a
film that has all this all this other
stuff in it and it might fail as a film
and people are going to say Oh Tarantino
blew it but could it possibly be that he
didn't have this relationship that he
already had right I mean so anyway so I
mean yeah there's there's a lot of work
to do that's just one area where you can
sort of think think things through very
differently one quick addition to
Danny's point on a timeline as far as
I've ever been able to tell the first
comics course toward a college was
Michael Uslan zat Indiana University in
72 so we're 40 years into somebody
teaching a course in comics one place
you can now get a minor in it at the
University of Oregon you can get a
masters in it at the Center for cartoon
arts university of florida has a minor
also yeah ok so we got to still no
departments as the guys pointed out at
I'm sorry ok i'm not i'm strictly
speaking about the u.s. it would shock
me if there wasn't much more yeah i mean
there there there there are places but
scats Katz's you're still the practical
it's not comic it's not comic studies
it's about learning to draw you've had
that a number of places for a longer
time but at any rate if it took us 40
years to get from one course to a minor
in a couple of places it's going to take
a while but this is a great step forward
and I'm profoundly grateful to all the
organizers for making this happen thank
thank you well I apologize NC a couple
of people standing up here but we're
only going to have time for one more
question and then and then I'm going to
make some quick closing remarks Eddie
I'm sorry sir ok I I mean obviously this
is a you know New York centric
conference and we've talked a lot about
American comics but there's this great
corpus of European Japanese comics
almost all cultures have these and no
mention has been made of them so matter
where you situate these traditions
within the study of graphic novels and
comics you know in courses in context as
best you can that they exist you try to
introduce the breadth of it I think to
the point of being New York centric the
first significant contact from the world
of band S&A to American comics was in 72
when a fan scholar named David Pascal
brought a gathering of the great French
bandhan des neige artists to New York to
introduce them to American comics and
through us miniature convention for them
to meet some of the American
practitioners and American fans and we
got to meet I was reminded of this the
other week when Jean juro past having
met him there when I was 15 this was the
place you took them to because this was
where it was and those those links have
existed for a long time it's a there are
very different traditions of comics
elsewhere in the world some of them easy
to connect some of them more challenging
to even as a non scholar begin to find a
language for and maybe that's something
where the interdisciplinary world can
help because surely there are professors
of world literature who have squamata
for analyzing these things that has poor
comic book people don't it's just bande
dessine are different right and the
kids here don't like it and we can't
really sell it
haha really cool though but unless it's
got naked women in it it doesn't do too
well oh right i mean i would i would say
that you know we look one of the things
if you know if I if I ever get get a
good grant proposal together one of the
things things things that I wouldn't do
is go to Paris and collect um French
language Arab comics right there are
there a bunch of like sort of like
protest counterculture comics being done
by like Algerians and people living in
the slums and France that doesn't ever
get here because you know the French I
mean the French are serious about their
culture and they're not going to put
something out and send it across the
pond that that sort of denigrates what
it is to be French right so this is like
oppositional culture at work and it is
sort of you know it goes on it's it's
red but it does it you know it goes on
archive right um but the other thing I
would say is like my students always
yell at me like we need manga we need
manga I'm like the ue Japanese right
because because you know and you know
you begin to talk about all the problems
of translation and transposition like
where they're putting the pages back to
forward and then a mix pages up all the
time why you don't think translation at
five dollars a page is being done to the
highest scholarly stand exactly right
and so I mean and so I mean this this is
it is a problem but I mean you know I
mean I am gonna do some sort of
international work but primarily you
know there's enough there's wait there's
more than enough work to be done in in
the in the English language context and
hopefully you know others can build
those bridges and I'll put a brick in
that when i get the paris in cycling
economics but you know there's there's
just there's just too much to be done oh
no my comics courses are always
international i started teaching at a
comparative literature Department it
always has to be international and I
think comics are one of the great
international dialogues you know Disney
tezuka Disney is really an important
dialogue bringing up father to air jay
is an important international dialogue
the liberation of French comics in the
1970s was due to the American
underground or chrome dome Mobius and
that's how i teach comics it's an
international dialogue both that
stylistically and narrative Lee you know
Superman to Super Heroes all over the
world and Superman is really the
the icon end and that's the way it needs
to be done and when I first started
teaching comics and complet I said you
know is it okay if my courses
international I want to cover Latin
America as well as North America and
francophone Canada and they said of
course that's what we do in rockland and
that's what it is it's a it's a dialogue
and you can teach it that way thank you
Chris and from the flights of
international activity and see if I'm
going to bring things a little bit
closer to home to make some quick
closing remarks that I'm going to segue
smoothly into right now and then they
will be followed by assigning for our
panels but first let me thank these
panelists for their for their wonderful
work and the group before you to the
left on the table is just the latest
iteration of a tremendous amount of
intellect wit charm and imagination that
has been going on for the last two days
so all of our panelists and all of our
moderators really deserve a great great
thanks from all of us I want to single
address a couple of people in
institutions for thank yous this is what
this part is and you know I'll be quick
but but heartfelt as I possibly can the
first briefly I mentioned this at the
beginning of the panel is to Chris couch
for the idea which started this all at
so Chris thank you
I'd like to now thank my co-organizers
one by one first Danny finger off
Danny's passion and his his deep
commitment and his intelligent his
respect for the people who have been in
this field in this industry really was
just was evident you know throughout the
entire thing and it was wonderful
working with you and it was an equal
pleasure working with Karen green so
first care if there was a word cloud of
my comments over the last couple of days
the word indefatigable would have
appeared sort of been big big letters
and that is because of Karen and every
time isn't it amazing and I was a
Karen's work on this has been
indefatigable and really just the amount
of energy and time and effort that she
put in was as awe-inspiring as the work
she's been doing for the last year's in
building up the collection issues a
wonderful partner please just one more
round of applause again if you will turn
to the back of your programs you will
see a list of institutions and
individuals that have sponsored and made
this happen please as we would say and
then the Jewish world take a look think
kindly of them they really this could
not have done without all not mention
them one by one but that's what the
programs for please think about them if
you meet any of them institutionally on
the street go up and thank them very
much I'd like to thank the person who is
now actually doing what I said and
looking at the back Chris Claremont
Chris if it wasn't for his generosity
and his vision both as a creator and
then as a donator we would not be able
to have this kind of celebratory
opportunity Chris it was in credit it's
been incredible getting to know you it's
incredible looking at your work both as
a child and now in the rare book and
manuscript library Chris thank
and I will end on behalf of the
University and the libraries with a with
I guess a what what Paul might call a
nudge and I would call a plea it this is
Columbia University in the city of New
York it's the columbia university
libraries in the city of new york and
the reason that chris's gift is so
wonderful is not only for what it does
on its own it gives us a tremendous
amount of knowledge and scholarship but
also as a catalyst for future people
many of the people who are represented
on this table in the table all for the
last two days to donate their work their
time and their treasures to us and to
future generations of scholars 20 years
from now if Karen and I are still doing
this we hope to have people say that
Chris's gifts and others have been the
basis of a renaissance of scholarly work
and so if you are someone who has these
materials if you know someone who has
these materials if you are willing to
get shy someone who has these materials
please please do so we here at the
library have and at the University have
open hands open hearts and open ears to
hear these kinds of opportunities so
please donate with wider width wide
hands in an open heart thank you all
very very much
thank you all thank you for that thank
you very much have a it was great being
with you for two days enjoy the shining
and have a great rest of the weekend
thank you
you